now some breaking news to tell you about
from Turkey where president erdogan has
said presidential and parliamentary
elections will be held on May 14th
earlier than the scheduled date in June
the vote will follow last month's
devastating earthquakes that killed more
than 45
000 people in Turkey alone and 50 000
across turkey and Syria let's go to our
correspondent synonym who's in Istanbul
so we had heard in the past that the
election date had been moved forward to
May 14th but this was before the
earthquakes I believe and the date is
still being maintained it would seem
cinnamon
yes definitely it was a date that
Turkish president
said he wanted this election to be held
as the June 18 date comes uh in between
the holiday dates in turkey and people
are traveling to other cities but we had
the earthquake in Turkey which affected
nearly 4 million people's lives and
affected 11 cities and there were some
suggestions even from the pro-government
AG party circles from its former a team
members that the election should be
postponed but according to the Turkish
Constitution except for the situation of
War election cannot be postponed the
official date for this 2023 election is
set for June 18 but technically this is
not an early election even if it's held
on May 14th it's just moving the day
forward as you have said currently we
know that Turkish president reject type
erdogan is the candidate of the
president Alliance represented by the
ruling equality and its Ally nationalist
party on the other side we have six
members of the opposition that
established the nation's Alliance and
we're expecting them to announce their
candidate for this presidential race so
far they haven't announced any names and
they are conflicting news coming from
the opposition Alliance but this is an
important step because because of the
earthquake there are so many logistical
challenges for the higher election board
and by March 10 the election board need
to officially announce it and the
election must be held within 60 days but
given the situation on the ground
probably it is true there's a lot of
questions indeed given the situation
that erdogan has lost popularity yeah
there are a lot of questions and I'm
sorry to interrupt you but it's it's
important to point these out issues here
because an election in two months when
the country is still dealing in with the
aftermath of the devastating earthquake
some provinces are still under an
emergency under emergency measures how
how will it work how will campaigning
work
thank you
exactly fully they're now 11 cities are
under state of emergency and as I said
we're talking about nearly 14 million
Turkish people and maybe nearly half of
them have been displaced and the
accommodation situation is not proper in
the field people are living in the tents
people are living in the containers many
of them have moved to different cities
to to live with their relatives or to
start a new life so despite the higher
election board said earlier that they
can do the arrangements logistical
arrangements for this election it seems
too difficult some some experts have
have suggested that this election should
be should be held online but whether the
uh infrastructure technical
infrastructure is ready for this is also
another question and of course the the
people in the region they are not in
good psychology they are really affected
by this earthquake and this is going to
be the most challenging election for
president erdon who is going to enter
his uh third decade in governing the
Turkish Republic thank you for that
Cinema
in Ankara